[Music]
how many of you guys listen to music
while having sex sometime sometimes
sometimes huh never go oh please don't
[Music]
most of the time it's a Netflix you like
to listen to the sounds of TV ready or
do you put an I like getting I like hang
on one second Netflix thought this that
was obvious you don't know the office I
wasn't paying attention
oh part of it yeah if it was on and then
ask for later and then it sucks cuz it's
like are you still watching that can be
a real killer
I mean there's Netflix I mean for you
watching a movie then does that set the
mood you think like psychologically is
there like a mood setter from a movie as
to posts like music no there's like
movies now that I feel are you gonna
watch with someone that does exactly
what yeah like what like a part of
shades like 50 shades or like that new
one that all that goes around 365 yeah
what's that one dude that guy won't like
like his name is like Michelle or
Michael whatever won't leave my feed
like my pictures only I can't he's
good-looking but like I really get like
you laggy won't leave my feet it's like
everything now yeah he's all over the
main character to that show I had to see
it he what would you say what did you
see it kind of look like you oh thank
you no all right anyway a new survey
done by who did this survey by a
lingerie brand called pour moi
or the alarm Walkman pours s Spanish
pou on like French wha mo I I mean yeah
for me
poor me more like like you poor
something but in France French I think
that's for and then I imagine a [ __ ]
poor me poor on them poor it just pours
out it's like it's like a piping bag
alright yeah draw with your dick yeah
it's like peeing and then you used to
write things on the wall but only write
a few letters that's can't write a novel
a few letters it's a lot yeah so yeah
this company this laundry company uh
named pour moi dinner research or I
guess a poll really of all their client
base of whether or not they listen to
music when they have sex and interesting
enough the weekend turned out to be the
number one artist and the weekend
you can't know I hate his [ __ ] voice
he's sounds like Michael Jackson second
Kyle make you horny is what she said
exactly like he's trying to hornoff I it
and I'm like that changing because I
know he's talking to a man
what is he gay I thought he was he was
with Bella [ __ ] how do you die think
sorry I just made that out of the
hadees' I just you just like either
display get off the ground right here I
know okay
every time I've like seen someone's like
sex playlist the weekends always there
everyone has it about my sex playlist
yeah oh we're old so we have like
genuine 112 well that's the same [ __ ]
more place of the gym hello Miguel how
many conversion I have a funny story
about a Miguel playlist my buddy
you know he had this Miguel playlist
he's playing he's hooking up with his
girl and he just letting it roll through
and the song comes on it's like tell me
that that [ __ ] yeah she goes can we
turn this off damn it's like now next
song man hit next some of his music
tomato trailers for uh yeah ricky 10
minutes ex-players for a riddle of it he
rapped or like started seeing his own
[ __ ] just to [ __ ] with them he didn't
get to that part I guess he busts it too
quick to get to that part that's pretty
funny that is funny buddy you hear I
feel like you should make a sex playlist
and just like put out to your fans and
then one of the songs in it was just
like [ __ ] up like it's not the bus or
something
boys I could [ __ ] to everything though
really so on this list the weekend you
could [ __ ] to the weekend Trey Songz uh
sure yeah Drake you're just shaking your
head on every one of them you just like
a [ __ ] to anything but I won't do it i
watch mmm yeah I retract my statement
instantly three three artists in he's
like I'm over three I'm not I didn't
know those are the artists I would I
guess that'd be what about these ones
Red Hot Chili Peppers yeah soul to
squeeze that's nice [ __ ] tight oh
yeah it's different kind of sex under
the [ __ ] bridge green dad no the
Green Day's on a list as well yeah Nine
Inch Nails no nine Angela they're pretty
hot
nine inches Oh true nobody or nailing
meals nine inch nails yeah the strangest
one on the list is Johann Sebastian Bach
that's some shot because I don't know
that not just Sebastian Bach like the
hair metal guy it's like actually
Germans 17th century driven composer
Johann oh I don't know Oliver's guy's
name ah good Oliver's out there why it's
like I mean it's really mentally
stimulating I'm a sapiosexual it's like
get me out of here famously he only
takes one have sex sorry
oh my god not that I mean by himself
yeah I got it okay those classical songs
do last a long time though I know
damn it is pretty long yeah how many
[ __ ] movements can you go through you
put it on or do you let the girl choose
like the playlists or songs the Netflix
show yeah you're lying to me I don't
know good choices so whoa wait what wait
the girls you date no good choices
no sometimes they put like uh I forgot
what was it it was like [ __ ] that I
don't want to watch if I'm actually
interested in watching something but you
know you're gonna [ __ ] who cares that's
why you can watch it again oh but then
you do get distracted cuz I remember I
was doing it and then wolf of wallstreet
was playing and I had to stop in the
middle of doggy style be like oh [ __ ]
what just happened I had to rewind it
what yeah you remember that time when I
when I used to live with you guys I was
I hate kidding I stay in your room and I
brought that girl her I was like the
whole time she was complaining about the
movie and I'm like yo why the [ __ ] why
you know we're on the couch outside the
room Oh your boner
he said sex on the couch no we learned
my room oh the whole time I was like
stories really on rats
[Laughter]
the whole time she put on was they won't
shut up about maybe she's like I want to
get out of here but she's like oh yeah
like I want to suck your dick he's like
yo dude she wouldn't shut up about the
movie it turned me off I probably won't
happen though well what are you guys
watching like Teletubbies you know they
made a movie I don't know but she didn't
like it yeah I feel like their [ __ ]
sometimes that we watch like this it
just happens while we're watching
something that Mike oh this is [ __ ]
weird
well something cuz since we're married
and we've been together for so long
there's no like there's no strategy you
know that that part of like I'm gonna
set the mood Frank with you you want to
have sex or tonight or no his story we
don't be gardening Paulie weeds and
we're just [ __ ] for no reason outside
like it's just it's just so weird yeah
but you say you're not we're not worried
about like Miguel pussy's mind coming on
it or being like this exactly so like
you know there's no like courtship where
you're kind of like if I play the wrong
song it's gonna turn off she's gonna dip
like that's not gonna happen
our sexual experience like we've been
tried one where like we started getting
horny and we're having sex but then I
think with the type of wake up from a
nap or something so we just throw a
blanket over she's like sitting on me
and we're just trying different
situations and we were talking about how
awkward it was wait so you guys were on
the couch yeah because you're like oh
yeah Tycho's show on the couch or piss
on a leak through is a I don't like all
the things they said on the couch huh
it's not on the couch
no Grover that time like last week that
you're not the one having sex on you
don't trip it has gonna kick girls out
clothes on - but this is marriage sex is
different it's like a different realm is
inside if there's a [ __ ] kid and then
yeah
let the kid there's the [ __ ] kid and
we're like tigers open some points from
and it keeps coming over and the more we
start moving the more he wants to come
over get excited hear that yeah alright
this is [ __ ] weird yeah yeah no we
had to stop and I'm like can I please
come and she's like no other money it's
weird what yeah it's really weird that's
that's marriage sex sex is very fickle
it's very like the slightest thing
throws it off I agree it's it's a little
bit different than just single guys sex
where there's like setting the mood and
the strategy in a game - do you guys try
that setting the mood yes in the mood I
don't know we did the lag a date one
date night or you guys didn't the light
do we I don't know I don't think we're
like that these lights on yeah we turn
on the light I did what's your manual
only cameras which light which lights
are the the bill saving ones
check your thermostat
[Music]